[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais ouais ouais dans un instant on
aura mike horn et zafira je peux vous
dire on va parler aventure on va se
détendre un peu vrai j'aime bien j'aime
bien j'ai bien le droit de vrais faux my
cordes s'appelle jessica sa fille
jessica horn 100 m e woods le beau gosse
pareil tu dis c'est qui ton ex mike horn
ça aurait fini s'équiperont makhloufi ou
alors hier sorcier vous avez voulu
rendre hommage à une autre idole votre
modèle en place en rayon et en coiffure
chuck norris parce que des gens pour qui
la passion ses voyages et de lire vos
autres passions c'est de casser des
plans frais c'est vrai c'est vrai et
quand vous casser des plongeurs chez des
gueules jeu mais on en parle tout à
l'heure de casal justement et quand vous
casser des planchers comme quand vous
chantez vous êtes premier degré ah ouais
vous n'est pas encore prêt pour
remplacer tout norris ne pas encore prêt
mais vous travaillez lechuck novices
pour l'instant j'ai très envie de faire
un gros spectacle de casse à la fin de
l'année qui sera vrai je te jure est
pour le dernier serait pas la même sans
déconner s'est réjoui participer enfin
non mais je cachais de casser le cul
asie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en général un animateur qu'on va
qualifiée de normale demande à ses
assistants de la portée des fiches et
voilà ce que demande cyril hanouna
et en général les matins qu'on qualifie
de normale ne passe pas son émission
attendait de casser des planches monde
après l'autre avec la main ces faits le
feront maintenant
plus difficile c'est planches avec le
coup de même jean claude van damme s'est
cassé les dents
[Applaudissements]
j'ai regardé réactions de vos
chroniqueurs le fameux mélange
d'admiration
des fois d' aberration vous avez compté
la pub après la main la tête et le cou
de voulait casser la planche avec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
évidemment nous avait réussi mais les
images sont interdites aux moins de 18
ans et dans six mois c'est votre
anniversaire cyril donc j'ai un petit
cadeau pour vous je crois vous allez
kiffer regarder mes pieds où je veux
c'est souvent dans laquelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je peux tu es loin je mets les pieds
c'est bon
depuis qu'elle est folle c'est génial
c'est que je passais mon j'ai regardé
tous les films je vous lis j'ai une
passion pour les films de bagarre je ne
regarde que ça pratiquement non mais
plus jamais les pieds ici bas et les
pieds où je m'engage et batman voir ça
je viens de voir il ya aussi je dirais
pas le mot mais dit dégage ici sinon je
te jure que tu vas finir avec la top
dans un tupperware
il est plus haut le mot qui dit quand
même assez sympathique crs accueillant
comme ça j'adore alors s'érige en parle
tout le temps avec moi mais vous formez
un duo ailleurs comme starsky et hutch
tango et cash et mon frère charlie et
lulu c'est vrai alors vous êtes prêts à
tout pour le faire et en fait j'adore de
prêts à tout pour lui faire mal aussi
ah oui ça c'est vrai alors c'est pas
vrai c'est mon ami à l'école on se
relance au chum c'est vrai on se
chiffonnent n'y a pas de problème mais
même s'il est difficile de percevoir le
regard de benji vous allez quand même
voir il est très expressif belgique
selon ce qui se passe dans l'émission la
preuve vous réduit
cinq grands enfants cancer il annonce au
nom de l'idée qui quand même très
original il est obligé de se mordre la
langue pour ne pas rigoler merci à
mettre de la suisse d'être avec nous
merci beaucoup avocat fiscaliste vous
allez nous expliquer pourquoi de plus en
plus vers tous évidemment ce qui nous
fait exprès le répéter encore et encore
le nom de la science et casas il ya plus
de mal à se contenir 100 coop compte
alger que le coronavirus regardez c'est
aux pmr six jours a remarqué m delassus
skate avec une merci
[Applaudissements]
et pour la première fois de sa carrière
on va voir casta les yeux grands ouverts
regardez ces réactions quand on reçoit
une ancienne candidate de secret story
qui l'a présentée et dont il a
absolument aucun souvenir
vous venez de ses critiques je les fais
6 tab story tout à fait la saison et
m'ont dit ce n'est pas le cas du
féminisme eu le meilleur avec casta
c'est que même s'il est habitué aux
frasques de son ami cyril hanouna
il arrive encore être traumatisé par une
vanne de l'inventeur de la barca c'est
assez violent ou envoi de sms
personne à part isabelle oui des fois je
me demande ce que ça cache
oui le jeudi tu dois peut-être trompé de
destinataire non maintenant j'avais
envie de tout bouffer le cul
[Musique]
débat pour vous ce yo mais je suis
choqué par l'attitude de casta showcase
ok je comprends on est un peu dans un
lycée et si je trouverais ce tpc un
lycée comme dans un lycée ça bosse pas
beaucoup et en fin d'année il y en a
beaucoup qui n'auront pas leur bac vous
allez voir parce qu'entre les fautes de
français les émissions qui regardent pas
cyril le prof ça vous énerve ça m'a fait
penser à la suite des sous-doués
s'appelle les sous doués de la télé
regardez
[Applaudissements]
alors là on est calée ni en langue
français n'y en ait souhaité ma femme
castaldi de la main sur le coeur et le
côté c'est la soirée des le des membres
de l'académie des césar même si le
bureau matin et et dissolue il salue
aussi mehdi ce sont surtout les 10 ou 20
le fait qu'elle ait une vie avant après
en son staff avaient pensé à l'instant
acheté la finale femmes pour vous
l'instant t on dit habitué à bac 5 pour
être prêt d'ici quelques semaines est
disponible sous 90 jours et le vice
président américain annonçait que ce
serait dans quelques mois
mais voilà exactement 90 jours ces trois
mois au lycée c'est le bénin ont fait
pas ses devoirs
quant à peu près par être question pour
l'inviter c'est comme en classe tu te
fais tout petit et comme par hasard
c'est un peuple
l'europe donne la parole j'ai moins peur
des dérapages pendant et depuis je fais
de la scène je me sens plus à la nation
kelly une question qu'on va bien et
souvenez-vous quand le prouva demande à
ses élèves de regarder un programme et
va en débattre en classe on se rend
compte que vraiment personne à bosser
c'est magnifique
cette allusion tu avais venus chez nous
non la ville attend si vous avez vous
avez des analyses mega
on a compris comment ça marche calais
schille christine a les chiffres j'ai
[Rires]
fait quelque chose certaine le prédateur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avait mois pour un balanceront peu
spéciale demain dès 20h45 un je vous le
dis balances ton poste dès 20h45 demain
vous terminez un petit peu plus tôt pour
bien entendu je vous appellerai ce soir
pour vous dire comment je vais défalquer
une dernière chose bien sûr une clameur
une dernière chose comme seydou par
alors si vous êtes comme moi vous si
vous trouvez un truc drôle vous pouvez
le regarder mais il faut enfin c'est
vrai c'est vrai alors c'est ce que vous
faites avec certaines de vos vannes
en fait vous êtes tellement fort que les
chroniqueurs rigole quand même à vos
blagues même si elles reviennent souvent
et vous peut-être que vous êtes comme
daury en fait je me suis dit connaissait
dori dans le monde de nemo à chaque fois
vous rappelle la chanson de la musique
la star academy de la musique
si nous on n'a l'amnésique achats d'or
par garder
oui la musique eux
série la semaine dernière vous nous
expliquer que jean-michel faisait des
vannes très drôle mais c'est tout le
temps les mêmes très bon et toujours
entre gilbert montagné capoter cette
vanne il a fait tous les jours surtout
oui mais voilà est drôle mais c'est vrai
qu'il a fait tous les jours sur et vous
comment vous faire tout le temps les
mêmes vins et franchement ça nous arrive
absolument jamais vous détestez allez on
souhaite le qazana ça on aura une
nouvelle a dit mitchell et jeux mortels
où la chanson française eddy mitchell
les yeux couleur menthe à aller tout de
suite une nouveauté c'est lui qui a les
yeux couleur vraiment vous fait un point
d'honneur depuis le début de la saison
de ne jamais répéter les mêmes vans
impossible qui a ouvert d'ailleurs un
camping moi je sais pas du cap d'agde
chapelle tatum est tout ouïe
j'ai montré le film à la d'actions
bouygues monte à la direction alors
regardez je leur ai zappé le cas du nord
est où il n'était pas du tattoo mais
tous bonjour est ce que votre surnom à
l'époque c'était toof tatum m'étouffe
j'avais tout aux boîtes aujourd'hui non
un look et je me suis emmerdé commença
le tout les mois
amnésie mais nos pauvres payent nos amis
les classiques et en attaque durant
toute la saison sur un oui n'est pas
c'est quoi comme musique la semaine
dernière van toorn amateurs de ces
nouveaux ces merdes matelas à mata va
tordre cia
mitchell d'aussi à laquelle je suis et
les phones téléphones
moi je ne comprends pas mais on a on a
effectivement de l'ancien aussi les
annonces et 10 non non non pour bientôt
non non c'est que les interviews de
personnalités ou te parler à quelque
chose de lui en suisse non au revoir
c'est tout remporté